[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
now lately i've made quite a few videos
where i've ranked the witches and
wizards of the harry potter universe
by power these lists included alumni
from hogwarts houses
auras order of the phoenix members and
even death eaters
no one witch or wizard made it into
every video but there were a few that
ended up on a couple of the lists
for example madaimudi made it to both
the top 5 aura's list
and top 5 order of the phoenix members
list
as power rankings are largely subjective
many of these videos were subject to
some controversy as every harry potter
fan undoubtedly feels differently about
which witches and wizards are more
powerful than others
one comparison that i noticed was
discussed quite a lot in the comments
across multiple videos was hogwarts
potions professor severus snape
versus hogwarts transfiguration
professor minerva mcgonagall
now the first thing that should be
mentioned is that both snape and
mcgonagall
are substantially more powerful than the
average witch or wizard
they're each at the top of their game in
their respective disciplines
and both hold a level of power that is
unlikely to be achieved by the vast
majority of the wizard population
so they're immensely powerful but one
has got to be
more powerful and in this video i'm
going to be answering the question
who is more powerful mcgonagall or snape
to better compare them let's take a
brief dive into each of their histories
and see if we can pick up any clues
along the way we'll start
chronologically and begin with minerva
mcgonagall
who is at least 25 years older than the
deceptively young snape
minerva mcgonagall's exact birth year is
unconfirmed
largely due to a blunder in the
fantastic beasts film that showed a
20-something mcgonigle
teaching at hogwarts in the 1920s
however fortunately we know just about
everything else about mcgonagall
minerva mcgonagall born to which isabel
ross and muggle robert mcgonagall
was a scottish half-blood witch that
hailed from scotland
from a very young age mcgonagall began
exhibiting signs of her magical
abilities
doing things like summoning toys to
herself and making the family cat
do her bidding for some witches and
wizards this can take some time
but for mcgonagall it was nearly
instantaneous
for many years minerva's father had no
idea that his wife
and minerva's mother was a witch but
because minerva began showing signs of
magic
very early on it became clear that she
would have to come clean
when mcgonagall became of age like many
other witches and wizards
she began attending hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
upon starting at the school she quickly
set herself apart from her fellow peers
boasting an immediate innate magical
proficiency for learning and performing
magic
she was the shining light of the school
during the time that she went there
and when it came time to test her
abilities in the form of owls and
newts mcgonagall achieved top grades she
was the most powerful student
of her entire year arguably the entire
school
and she showed a particular affinity for
transfiguration
which is a particularly complex form of
magic when she had finally finished her
studies her future certainly looked
bright
as her impressive performance at school
meant that a job offer at the ministry
of magic
was sitting and waiting for her after
returning home for a brief period
mcgonagall accepted the job at the
ministry in the department of magical
law enforcement
and similar to the time that she was in
school impressed everyone
even though her job was going really
well mcgonagall eventually decided
that she wanted to be closer to home
which led to her application
to hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry almost instantly
mcgonagall was offered a posting in the
transfiguration department
mcgonagall later becomes head of the
but at this time she was working under
the existing department head
albus dumbledore given that dumbledore
is arguably one of the most powerful
wizards to have ever lived
and that he himself is particularly
skilled at transfiguration
it must have really been a valuable
experience for her to work underneath
him
and i'm certain that it sharpened and
harnessed her transfiguration
capabilities
bringing them to a new level altogether
severus snape
like mcgonagall grew up with one muggle
and one wizarding parent
on january 9th 1960 severus was born
to which eileen prince and mughal to buy
a snape
in the small muggle town of spinner's
end spinner's end was very close to the
nearby town of cokeworth
where snape would later meet lily evans
a girl that he would become deeply
infatuated with
in their youth the pair were inseparable
and they spent a considerable amount of
time together
before embarking on their journey to
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
1971 was the year that they left for
hogwarts
and it was supposed to be the time of
their lives however
in reality this was the year that marked
the beginning
of snape's tragedy as in that same year
him and lily
were sorted into different houses snake
was sorted into slytherin
and lily to gryffindor this immediately
placed divide
between them to add insult to injury
lily's later husband
james potter was also sorted into
gryffindor and it just so happened
that he was severus snape's main bully
at school
but snape didn't just have one bully he
had four the marauders
sirius black remus lupin peter pettigrew
and james and they made his life
miserable snape's incessant bullying
during school
inevitably sent him down a very dark
path and snape was really not the guy
they should have done that too because
in reality he was the most
innately powerful wizard of his entire
year before even attending hogwarts
snape was passionate about performing
magic
and learning new spells he didn't even
have a formal education
but probably knew more than most
hogwarts graduates the following quote
from sirius
supports this snape knew more curses
when he arrived at school
than half the kids in seventh year so
what should the marauders not have done
with a powerful wizard like snape the
answer is of course
bully him until he turned to the dark
arts snape's introduction to the dark
arts
was never good for anyone particularly
because he was so talented
he excelled in all of his classes at
school aced tests easily
and devoted all of his spare time to
studying independently
after hours his future was extremely
promising
and while learning his primary course
material at hogwarts would even scribble
in his notebook
and invent his own curses charms and
potions snape even produced his own
version
the potion's class textbook under the
alias the half blood prince
and the spells that he created were
leaps and bounds ahead of what any of
his peers would have been able to do
snape's natural talent paired with his
incessant thirst for knowledge
and willingness to pursue even the
darkest forms of magic
meant that snape graduated hogwarts a
very powerful man
perhaps one of the most powerful people
that the school had ever produced
if we look at the upbringings and
history of both snape and mcgonagall
we can see that they were both
incredibly impressive students with some
of the highest levels of innate magical
ability
around on top of that they were both
studious and took magic very seriously
in a lot of ways particularly as
students they were very similar
but the primary difference between them
was of course the path they took
after finishing school mcgonagall left
school and pursued a respected job at
the ministry
with predictable hours and a great
starting salary
snape on the other hand left school
still fueled
with immense rage and a strong desire to
enact his revenge
on those who had wronged him so they're
both massively talented
but who is the more powerful between
them in harry potter and the deathly
hallows
we actually get to see snape and
mcgonagall face off the movie depicts it
like a stalemate
it basically looks like neither of them
are winning snape eventually retreats
which sort of gives the viewer the
impression that he was losing
but in reality he really wasn't snape
was still acting as a double agent
at this point in time and barely anyone
including mcgonagall
knew that snape was actually one of the
good guys when mcgonagall began
attacking snape
he fought back because if he didn't it
would have been very unusual
and he probably would have blown his
cover when she started attacking him
snape fought back however he did so with
only the exact amount of effort
necessary
and not a touch more because he never
had any intention
of defeating mcgonagall he just wanted
to hold her off
a lot of people interpreted this as
mcgonagall beating snape
but that just isn't the case if we look
at the fact that mcgonagall was actively
trying to defeat snape
while snape snipwitch is putting in the
minimum amount of effort it tells me
that snape is certainly the more
powerful wizard
how much snape is actually holding back
is unclear
but if he had wanted to destroy her i
think he really could have
mcgonagle was an accomplished witch with
an extremely impressive knowledge of
magic
and many different skills under her belt
she was a powerful duelist
impressive potion maker charms expert
transfiguration master
and even dabbled in the dark arts
however i think that the only area
of magic the mcgonagall truly surpassed
snape in was transfiguration
it's not that mcgonagall was weak she
was amazing but snape
had a point to prove to the world he was
bullied and bullied
and this instilled a never stop attitude
in him which meant that he was
continually pushing the limits
of his magical abilities he was never
content
and he constantly pushed the boundaries
in order to become more
and more powerful not only that but
snape explored an entire other side of
the magical spectrum
that mcgonagall only scratched the
surface of i truly think that
in terms of the power of modern day
witches and wizards
snape would only be ranked after perhaps
dumbledore voldemort
and grindelwald he died at the tender
age of 38
and if he had lived for another 77 years
matching the age of dumbledore
at his death there's no telling what
severus snape would have been able to
achieve
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think who do
you think is more powerful do you agree
with me do you not
who should i do this for next let me
know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
harry
you